So we talked a lot about domain and range in this lesson so far, but I want to
give you a slightly different perspective on how to visualize them, and how to
think about values of the domain through the relation of a function mapping to
values in the range. So let's say we have some function f and for three to our
values a, b and c, constants not exactly sure what they are, we get outputs of
one, four, and five. We know that if we graph this, we would pair the
coordinates a and 1, b and 4, and c and 5. And what the function is really doing
is taking this input value, playing with it somehow, and spitting out this
output. So you could visualize this by writing out values of the domain over
here, and then showing that via the function, they get paired with these values
in the range. Let's say actually that for this particular function f, a, b and c
are the only values in the domain. So if the entire domain of this function is
just the set a, b, c, what values are in the range? Please separate any values
that are in the range by commas.